ciao a tutti sotto il video di instagram
ricevuto un bel po di commenti diverso
che mi chiedono di parlare di una
persona molto per chi non lo sapesse
facebook è il social col numero di
iscritti più grande al mondo nonché
l'unico dove per iscriversi è necessario
farsi una lobotomia prima scherzo no con
questo video e non voglio assolutamente
dire che facebook se un posto fatto
solamente per giovani gattare o per
quarantenni che scrivono caffè con k no
in realtà facebook alcune cose buone le
fan come ricordarti compleanni delle
persone delle quali non te ne frega la
fama
oppure ma oltre tutti i suoi pregi
facebook anche qualche difetto e
probabilmente tra quei difetti ci sei
anche tu che stai guardando questo
partiamo dalle basi facebook ai poteri
trasformare le persone i maiali come
circe io conosco delle persone che nella
vita reale sono persone normalissime
però poi su facebook possono delle foto
che sembrano delle retto scopi e senza
contare che un tempo esistevano degli
step per conquistare il cuore di una
giovane donzella facebook eliminati
tutti quelli come ci provano in chat
cioè sono proprio signori di altri tempi
cose carine attivate dal milan con le
frasi motivazionali la felicità non è un
viaggio sono una meta ma li mortacci tua
che l'altro ieri stavi menardi tra un po
con un magrebino solamente perché voleva
vendermi l'accendino al semaforo
il sorriso i merita medicina senza
controindicazioni che forte che
conoscono ma mente faide coca con tonio
cartoni sai quando reader o io quando
tutti ti prenderanno il computer pro
bruceranno in un falò alimentato da cui
status sta facendo buio cambio di luci
che io su facebook re un'amica che
costava tutte ma status anche belli c'è
tipo quelli sui bambini o sugli animali
che sono gli amici dell'uomo o sulla
legge dell'attrazione capito sta roba
qua no poi era la stronza c'è ma la
legge dell'attrattore c'è ed è quello
che te passa sopra la schiena appena
metà bici di facebook poi quel posto
pieno di coppi coppie che riescono a
piegare le leggi dello spazio e del
tempo perché festeggiano l'anniversario
ogni tre settimane coppie che si amano
coppie che litigano coppie che fanno
pace e io resto a casa al limon armi il
mio camera mauri te senza contare che io
ho voluto continuare
a limonare lo vita natural durante se
vai continuo ad attaccarmi e le foto in
cui sembra la sorella sfatta di jack
black
io lo dico semi targate in una foto dove
sono venuto un cesso io vengo alla
macchina vendola tua anima una zingara
senza denti tuato visto che quel posto
dove le persone durante l'ultimo
terremoto quello in umbria hanno scritto
alcuni dei contatti sto bene sto greco
amica pizzo calabro zio has made at è
arrivato capito trattata tonificato i
glutei quella scossa e poi su facebook
ragazzi smettetela di invitarmi e candy
crash saga specialmente pezzi a me fa
cagare quella cosa con le caramelle
gelatinosa e ti giuro ti giuro basta
basta non te le parole jack facebook
quel posto che ci si lancia frecciatine
cazzo così su status pubblici senza
manca avere la mira che ogni volta mi
sento preso in causa anche se non ti
conosco penso che sta parlando di me
perché non so la coda di paglia io sono
direttamente lo spaventapasseri il mio
fuoco così ma perchè non ve ne andate a
cagare in privato facebook e quel posto
dove ti chiedono l'amicizia persone che
vivono dall'altra parte del mondo ma che
a risiko dove tutti cercano di trovare
con tutti che sembra un concerto di
ottoni ma sopra ogni altra cosa facebook
e quel posto dove si potrebbe averci di
5.000 amici ma il venerdì sera magni
sempre da solo
e questa era tutto sterpete colto la mia
sottile ironia nel frattempo sono
appollaiati ad un pappagallo su questa
sedia fatemi sapere cosa li avevo invece
di facebook o cosa abbiate della vita in
generale che devi liberi di aprirvi con
me se questo video vi è piaciuto mettete
un po di censo condividetelo 1 su
facebook tacca degli occhi dai social
fondatore tipo a fraternizzare quelle
persone vere quelle che puzzano anni dal
mio canale
il suo tarlo e complete per vedere i
miei video che il braccio e mi vedrò al
prossimo video che non so quando uscirai
ciao
[Musica]